The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, so
today what we're going to do
is we're just start with
a short review problem
on rugged landscapes,
just so that you
get some sense of
the kind of thing
that I would expect you to be
able to do a week from today.
And then we'll get into the
core topic of the class, which
is evolutionary game theory.
And we'll discuss
why it is that you
don't need to invoke any
notion of rationality, which
is kind of the traditional
thing we do when we're
talking about game theory
applied to human decision
making.
Then we'll try to
understand this difference
to know what a Nash equilibrium
is in the context of game
theory versus an
evolutionary stable strategy
in this context.
And we'll say something about
the evolution of cooperation
and experiments that one can
do with microbial populations
in the laboratory.
Are there any questions
before I get started?
All right, so just on this
question of evolutionary paths,
on Tuesday we discussed
the Weinreich paper
where he talked about
sort of different models
that you might use to try to
make estimates of the path
that evolution might take
on that fitness landscape
that he measured.
So he measured this MIC,
the minimum inhibitory
concentration, on all 2 to
the 5 or 32 different states,
and then tried to say
something about the probability
that different
paths will be taken.
So I just want to
explore this question
about paths in a
simpler landscape, where
by construction here, I'm to
going to give you some fitness
values just so that we
can be clear about why
it is that there might
be different paths,
or what determines
the probability
that different paths are taken.
So what we want to
do is assume that we
are in a population that is
experiencing this Moran process
or Moran model, constant
population size N equal to,
in this case, we'll say 1,000.
And let's say that the mutation
rate is 10 to the minus 6.
So each time that an
individual divides, it has a 1
in a million
probability of mutating.
And that's a per base
pair mutation rate.
And I'll show you
what I mean by that.
And in particular, we're
going to have genotypes.
Originally when
we discussed this,
we were talking about just
mutations, maybe A's and B's.
But now, what
we're going to have
is just a short genome
that's string length 2.
So we might have 0, 0, which
has relative fitness 1, 0, 1.
So we're assuming that
this is relative fitness
as compared to the 0, 0 state.
We're going to start in
the 0, 0 state with 1,000
isogenic individuals, all 0, 0.
And the question is, what's
going to happen eventually?
And in particular, what path
will be taken on this landscape
here?
In particular, what
we want to know
is the probability
of taking this path.
You can start thinking
about it while I write out
some possibilities
that we can vote for,
and I'll give you a
minute to think about it.
So don't--
Are there any questions about
what I'm trying to ask here?
AUDIENCE: So this
is the long time?
So we assume that
in the long time,
it will go from 0, 0 to 1, 1?
PROFESSOR: That's right, yes,
so if we wait long enough,
the population will get
there, and the 1, 1 genotype
will fix in the population.
We can talk a bit later
about how long it's
going to take to get
there, and so forth.
AUDIENCE: And we're
assuming that from 0, 1,
it can't go back to 0, 0?
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah, so we'll
discuss the situations
when we have to
worry about that,
and when we don't, and so forth.
But for now, if
you'd like, we can
say that this is even just mu
sub b, the beneficial mutation
rate per base pair, assuming
that the 0's can only
turn into 1s.
Then after we think
about this, we
could figure out if
that's important,
or when it's important,
and so forth.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
All right, so we're starting
with all 1,000 individuals
being in the 0, 0
state, because now we're
allowing some mutation rate.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: And you
also have to think
about this first mutation--
will it fix or not?
AUDIENCE: But it's not
[INAUDIBLE] first mutation,
the mutation of one
element of that population
will go to 0, 1 [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I'm not sure if
I understand your question.
AUDIENCE: So if we start out
with all 0, 0, and then one
mutation [INAUDIBLE]?
And if that mutation--
are we assuming
that that mutation is 0, 1 and
then figuring out [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, OK,
you're asking kind
of what I mean by path here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I guess.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, all
right, so I'll say path
means that that this was
the dominant probability
trajectory of the
population through there.
We'll also discuss
whether it somehow
is very likely is going to
kind of have to go through one
or the other of them.
The probability of getting both
mutations in one generation
is going to be 10
to the minus 12.
So that's going to be a very
rare thing, at least given
these parameters, and so forth.
And then there's another
question, which is,
will 0, 1 actually
fix in the population
before you later
fix this population?
And actually, I think the
answers to all these questions
are in principal
already on the board.
Because there's a
question of do we
have to worry about
clonal interference?
Are these things neutral or not?
And really, this is in some
ways a very simple problem.
But in another way,
you have to keep
track of lots of
different things,
and which regime
we're in and so forth.
So that's what makes it such
a wonderful exam problem.
If you understand
what's going on,
you can answer it in a minute.
But if you don't
understand what's going on,
it'll take you an hour.
Yes?
No?
Maybe?
Well, I'll give you
another 20 seconds.
Hopefully, you've
been thinking about it
while we've been talking.
All right, do you
need more time?
Why don't we go ahead and vote?
I think it's very
likely that we will not
be at the kind of 100%
mark, in which case
you'll have a chance to talk
about it and think about it
some more.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
OK, all right, so we do have
a fair range of answers.
I'd say it might be kind
of something like 50-50.
And that's great.
It means that there should
be something to talk about.
So turn to a neighbor.
You should be able
to find somebody
that disagrees with you.
And if everyone around you
agrees, you can maybe--
all right, so there's a group
of D's and a group of B's here,
which means that everybody--
AUDIENCE: Let's fight.
PROFESSOR: All
right, so everybody
thinks that everybody
agrees with them,
but you just need to look a
little bit more long distance.
So turn to a pseudo-neighbor.
You should be able to
find somebody there.
It's roughly even here, so you
should be able to find someone.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
So I don't see much in the
way of vibrant discussion
and argument.
You guys should be passionately
defending your choice here.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Yeah, that's a
higher order point.
I wouldn't worry about that.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
All right, it looks like people
are having a nice discussion.
But I might still go
ahead and cut it short,
just so that we can get on
to evolutionary game theory.
But I would like to
see where people are.
And we'll discuss it
as a group, so don't
be too disappointed if you
don't get finished there.
But I do want to see
kind of where we are.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
OK, so it still is, maybe,
split roughly equally between D
and maybe a B-ish and some C's.
All right, does somebody want
to volunteer their explanation?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm not
sure how good it is,
but I was thinking about
what's the probability of going
to 0, 1 instead of 1, 0.
And I just took it as the ratio
of the extra benefit of 0, 1
over the benefit of 1, 0.
PROFESSOR: Sure, OK,
and just to start out,
which answer are
you arguing for?
AUDIENCE: D.
PROFESSOR: D, OK, all right.
So you're saying D. And
you're saying, all right,
maybe because of the
extra, that 1, 0 is somehow
more fit than 0, 1.
And you've taken some
relative rates or ratios
for which reason?
AUDIENCE: Well, I took 0.02
and then 0.1, which is 1/5.
And then I decided
that that should
be around what it is, but
slightly less, because there's
also a chance that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, yes.
I think the arguments
there-- there's
a lot of truth to the
arguments that you're saying.
Yeah, it's a little--
right and another question
is exactly why might it
be 1/6 instead of 1/5 is,
I think, a little bit
hazy in this here.
It's OK, but it's close.
Does somebody want to
offer an explanation?
So here, that was an argument
of roughly maybe why it's D-ish.
Because D is very
different from B--
order of magnitude different.
So can somebody offer why their
neighbor thought it was B?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I knew that it was
B, because I considered the two
paths, both from 0, 0 to 0, 1.
I first checked S, N
and it's non-neutral.
So probably [INAUDIBLE]
S. So the probability
for that first path
would be the S for 0, 1,
so it's 0.02, which is 1/50,
multiplied by the probability
that the other [INAUDIBLE] 1,
0 would die out [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, so there
are two related questions.
And I think that
this explanation here
is answering a slightly
different question.
OK, so let me try
to explain what
the two questions are here.
So the question that
you're answering
is, if you have kind
of 998 individuals that
are 0, 0 individuals, and
you have one that's 0, 1,
and you have one
individual that is 1, 0.
So this is like these problems
that we did a couple weeks ago,
where we said, you imagine
in the population you have
a couple different kinds of
mutants that are present maybe
in one copy.
And then we were
asking, well, what's
the probability that this
individual is going to fix?
And what's the probability this
And what's the probability
that these guys are
going to go extinct, and
this one will therefore fix?
And I think that's the
calculation that you're
describing, where
you say, OK, well,
in order for this
individual to fix,
he has to survive stochastic
extinction, which happens
with the probability of 2%.
And the 1, 0 individual
has to go extinct,
which happens 90% of the time.
And so this is, indeed,
answering the question
that if you had one copy of each
of these two mutant individuals
in the population,
that's the answer to what
is the probability
that this 0, 1 mutant
would fix in the population.
Right?
But that's a slightly different
question than if we ask,
we're going to start with an
entire population at 0, 0,
and now these mutations
will be occurring randomly
at some rate.
And then something's
going to happen.
Somehow the population
is going to climb up
this fitness landscape.
And we're trying to figure
out the relative probability
that it's going to take
kind of one path or another.
Do you see the difference
between these two questions?
So indeed, this is the correct
answer to a different question.
And so it's going
to end up being D.
And now we want to try to
figure out how to get there.
Because I think it
is a bit tricky.
And in order in order to
figure out to get there,
we have to make sure
we keep track of which
parameter regime we're in.
So there are a couple of
questions we have to ask.
First of all, we
have to remember
that we start out with
everybody, all 1,000
individuals in the 0, 0 state.
So there are initially no
mutants in the population.
But they're just
replicating at some rate.
And every now and then,
mutation's going to occur.
Now one thing we have to
answer, we have to think about,
is whether these are
nearly neutral mutations.
Verbally yes or no?
Ready?
Three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No, right.
And that's because
we want to ask
for, if it's nearly
neutral, we want to ask,
is the magnitude of S times
N much greater or much less
than 1?
In particular, if they're
much greater than 1,
as is the case here, then
we're in a nice, simple regime.
And it's easy to get
paralyzed in this situation,
because there's more than
one S. But in both cases,
S times N is much larger than 1.
We can take the smaller
S, which is 2 over 100,
and S times N is 20, right?
So S for the 0, 1
state times N is 20,
which is much greater than 1.
What this tells us
is that if we do
get this mutant appearing
in the population,
then he or she will have a
probability S of surviving
stochastic extinction.
So probability of surviving
stochastic extinction
if the individual
appears is equal to S 0,
1, which is equal to 2%.
Whereas for the 1, 0 state,
that's going to be 0.1.
Now, this is assuming
that the mutation appears
in the population, that's the
probability it will survive
stochastic extinction.
Now, just as a reminder,
surviving stochastic extinction
roughly corresponds to this
becoming an established idea.
And becoming established
was what again?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: S1 is [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's when S1--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's right.
All right, so established--
when we say established,
what we mean is that
this corresponds
to saying that this probability
that we talked about
before this X sub i is
approximately equal to 1.
So this question is, how
many individuals do you
have to get to in the
population before you're
very likely to fix?
And what we found is that that
number established went as 1
over the selection coefficient.
So in this case, you would
need to have 50 individuals
before you were kind of
more likely to fix than not.
So if you want to
be much more likely,
you might need twice that or so.
Do you guys remember that?
This is not important for
this question, necessarily,
but it might be important
at a later date.
AUDIENCE: And so for
nearly neutral mutations,
the whole point is
that the number needed
to become established is
equal to the population.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so everything
kind of works, right?
OK, so the way that we
can think about this
is, now we have this
population, 1,000 individuals.
They're dividing at some rate.
Mutations are going to appear.
Now we know if they did appear,
the probability they would fix.
This is assuming there's no
clonal interference, right?
Because if there's
clonal interference,
then surviving
stochastic extinction
is not the same thing as fixing.
If they both appear
in the population,
and they both survive
stochastic extinction,
then this mutant
loses to this mutant.
That's the clonal interference.
Do we have to worry about clonal
interference in this situation?
So remember, this was
comparing the two time scales.
This was comparing
the time between
successive establishment events,
which went as 1 over mu N S.
And the other one is the
time between the time to fix,
which went as 1 over
S log of NS, right?
So we can ignore
clonal interference
if this is much
larger than that.
So no clonal
interference corresponds
to mu N log NS much less than 1.
No clonal interference,
same as this statement.
Is that right?
Did I do it right?
OK.
So and once again, there
are multiple S's, and it's
easy to get kind of
upset about this.
But you can just use
whichever S would be--
which S would you want
to use to be kind of--
AUDIENCE: Small or
large [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: To be on the
safe or conservative side,
we want to take this to
be as big as possible.
So we take S actually
as big as we can, right?
It's in the log.
So details, right?
But we can see we have 10
to the minus 6, 10 to the 3,
and then this is the
log of maybe 100, which
is, like, 4 or 5.
Is it closer to 4 or 5?
I don't know, but
it doesn't matter.
We'll say 5.
This is indeed much less than 1.
So indeed, we
don't have to worry
about clonal interference.
This is a wonderful
simplification.
What it's saying is that
the population is dividing.
Every now and then, a mutation
occurs in the population.
It could be either
the 0, 1 or the 1, 0.
But in either case, the
fate of that mutation
is resolved before the
next mutation occurs.
So you don't need
to worry about them
competing in the population.
Instead, just at some constant
rate they're appearing.
And given that they appear,
there's some probability
that they're going to fix.
So that leads to effective
rates going to each of those two
steps-- going to 0, 1 or 1, 0.
And in particular, this is like
a chemical reaction, where we
have some chemical state here.
We have two rates.
There's the k going to 0,
1, the k going to 1, 0.
And what we know is we know
the ratio of those rates.
And that's everything
we need to know
to calculate the relative
probabilities of taking
those states, because the
probability of going through
to 0, 1-- we want to go
that direction-- 0, 1, this
is going to be given by k 0, 1
divided by k 0, 1 plus k 1, 0.
So this is how we get
1/6 instead of 1/5.
Because this thing
is 1/5 of that.
So it's like 1, and then 1, 5.
So this is actually, in
principle, not quite answering
the question that I
asked, because this
is talking about the relative
probability of the first state,
the first mutant to fix.
In principle, it is possible
that from there, there's
some rate of coming back.
Or they might not necessarily
move forward on up that hill.
Do you guys understand
what I'm talking about?
Because it goes
from here to there.
Because we really want to
know about this next step,
going to the 1, 1 state.
But in this case do we have to
worry about going backwards?
No.
And why not?
It's very unlikely.
And in particular,
you could think now
that you're here you can
talk about the rate of going
to the 1, 1 state as compared
to the rate of going to 0, 1.
And those are going to be
exponentially different.
Because just as this was
a non-neutral beneficial
mutation, that means
that going from 0,
1 back is going to be a
non-neutral deleterious
mutation.
So the probability of fixing it
in the back direction is not 0,
but it's exponentially
suppressed.
I think it's very
important to understand
all the different pieces
of this kind of puzzle,
because it incorporates many
different ideas that we've
talked about over
the last few weeks.
If there are questions,
please ask now.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What about
the [INAUDIBLE]?
[INAUDIBLE] 0, 0
to 1, 0 to 1, 1?
Then it seems like the benefit
of 1, 0 versus [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All right, so
you're wondering about--
so the fitness of the
1, 1 state was 1.2.
So you're pointing out
that it's actually easier
to go from the 0, 1
state to the 1, 1 as
compared to the
1, 0 to the 1, 1.
AUDIENCE: Right, which
seems like a reason for why
we wouldn't care
about [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK, right.
So if anything,
in some ways, this
actually provides a bias
going towards the 0, 1 state,
because it's saying that
if we do get to 0, 1,
it's actually easier
to move forward as
compared to this other path.
In practice, it doesn't
actually matter,
because this acts as a ratchet.
Because all these
mutations are non-neutral,
once you fix this state or
this one, you can't go back.
So the population
will move forward
once it gets to one
of those two states.
Now I mean, it would be a
very interesting question
to ask if we instead did
a different arrangement.
What would the rate of
evolution be, and so forth?
Yeah, but what you're
saying is certainly true,
that if this took up all
of the benefit going here,
then it may not
actually be somehow
an optimal path in terms of the
rate of evolution or something
like that.
I'll think about
that when designing.
Problems.
AUDIENCE: In this system, 0,
0 eventually becomes 1, 1.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: So the
probability is 1.
PROFESSOR: That's right,
so we are guaranteed
that we will eventually evolve
to this peak in the fitness
landscape.
And so what we're asking here
is which of these two paths
is going to be taken.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so how
to mathematically prove
that the system will
go from 0, 0 to 1, 1?
PROFESSOR: I mean, I feel
like I kind of proved it,
although I understand that
nothing I said was rigorous.
And of course, there are
non-zero probabilities
of going backwards.
It's just that they are reduced.
And actually, you can
prove, for those of you
who are interested
in such things,
that over long time
scales, there's
going to be an equilibrium
that distribution
over all these states, where
the probability of being
in a particular state will--
it goes as the fitness.
It scales as the relative
fitness to the Nth power.
So we talk about these
fitness landscapes
as energy landscapes.
And indeed, in this regime where
you have small mutation rates,
then it's going to be
a detailed balance.
And it's actually a
thermodynamic system.
So then in that case, you
can make a correspondence
between everything that
we normally talk about,
where fitness is like
energy and population
size is like temperature.
So the relative amplitude of
being in this peak as compared
to the other states is
going to be, in this case,
the ratios of those things
is, indeed, described
by the ratios of the fitnesses.
And it's going to go as kind of
like 1.1 to the 1,000th power,
which is big.
Which means that the
population has really
cohered at this peak in
the finished landscape.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if you want to
calculate a problem going
from 0, 1 to 0, 0,
then [INAUDIBLE]
that would just be--
I guess I'm not sure.
PROFESSOR: OK, you
want to know the rate
that that's going to happen.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: No, that's fine.
Let's do that.
So for example,
let's imagine that we
don't have-- so let's imagine
that we just have the 0, 0
and the 0, 1 states, just
so we don't have to worry
about going up the landscape.
And so what we have is we have r
is relative fitness 1 and 1.02.
Now what we want to do
is we want to ask, well,
what is the rate of
going back and forth?
Well, so the rate
of going forward,
well, we sample
mutations at a rate mu.
And this is mu only
for this one state,
because pretend that we're not
going to mutate this other one.
So rate mu N, you have
mutations appearing.
And times this s, 0.02,
is the probability
that it'll actually fix
in the forward direction.
And now what we want to know
is the rate of coming back.
Well, the beginning
part's the same,
because we have mu N
is the rate that you
get this deleterious
mutant in the population.
But then we need to multiply it
by the probability of fixation.
And the probability
of fixation is--
there was this thing X1, which
was 1 minus-- now this is r,
but it's r in the other
direction, so be careful.
Because the general
equation was 1 over.
But now r, instead of
being 1.02, is 1/1.02.
So which of these terms
is going to be dominant?
This thing gets up to be
some really big number
is our problem.
So we should be able to
figure this out, though.
Because this new r is 1/1.02.
So we for example, have 1
minus 1.02, 1 minus 1.02
to the 1,000.
All right, so this
is a negative number,
but this is a
negative number, too.
So we end up with 0.02--
AUDIENCE: 200.
PROFESSOR: Is it 200?
Yeah, you're keeping
only the first,
which, since it's much larger
than 1, it's bigger than 200.
Right?
I mean do you guys
understand what I'm saying?
You can't keep just the
first term in a series.
If the terms grow with number.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
squared, 3.98 or something.
PROFESSOR: Wait, which one?
AUDIENCE: 1.02 to the 1,000.
PROFESSOR: It's 4?
OK, all right.
OK, so it's 1 minus 4.
So it's 2/300.
OK, so this is teamwork, right?
OK, so there's less than a
1% probability of it fixing.
Is this believable?
AUDIENCE: It's about right.
PROFESSOR: 2,
1,000, 50-- I think
that you did it 1.02 to the 100
rather than 1.02 to the 1,000.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: No?
Do you not have it
in front of you?
AUDIENCE: No, it's
3-- [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: 4 times 10 to the 8.
AUDIENCE: I never thought
that my calculator
would become so controversial.
AUDIENCE: Oh, 4
times 10 to the 8.
PROFESSOR: Yes, sorry,
I was just saying this
doesn't-- so this is why I'm
saying you always check to make
sure that your calculation
makes any sense at all.
So it's not this.
But it's tiny, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because
this didn't make sense,
because this was of the
same order as-- well,
this would be larger than 1 over
N, so it's totally nonsensical.
Because 1 over N would be
the probability of fixation
of a neutral mutation.
This is a deleterious mutation.
It's not even nearly neutral.
So it has to be much less
than 1 over N, right?
So this whole thing
is 10 to the minus 10,
or something like that?
OK, 4 times 10 to the minus 8.
Well, OK, whatever.
It's 10 to the minus 9.
It's something small.
So this times the probability of
fixation, which is 10 minus 9--
this is how you would calculate
the rate of going backwards.
There's some rate that
the mutation appears,
and you multiply by the
probability that it would fix.
And it's tiny.
OK?
All right, any other
questions about how
to think about these sorts
of evolutionary dynamics
with presence of mutation,
fixation, everything?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can we
handle a situation
where [INAUDIBLE] interference
is important at this point?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so this is
what you do in your problem set
with simulations.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] numerical.
PROFESSOR: You know,
I think that it
gets really messy with clonal
interference, I'll say.
AUDIENCE: But,
like, with basic--
I guess I was thinking about
it and you could probably
imagine that [INAUDIBLE]
calculate the probability
that 1, 0 doesn't arise first.
PROFESSOR: Right, yeah, OK,
this is an important statement.
In the limit, as you get
more and more mutations, when
clonal interference
is really significant,
then you're pretty
much just guaranteed
to take the 1, 0 path.
Because if you
have many mutants,
the definition of clonal
interference is you
have multiple mutations
that have established.
And once you have
multiple mutations that
have established, then it's
likely that one of them
is going to be this.
And if it's established,
it's going to win.
But the other thing is that as
you go up in the mutation rate,
you don't even do
successive fixations.
So it may be that neither
state ever actually fixes,
because it could be
that the 1, 0 state
is growing exponentially, but
is a minority of the population.
And it gets another mutation
that allows it to go to 1, 1.
So as you increase
the mutation rate,
you don't have to actually
take single steps.
You can kind of
move through states.
And there's a whole literature
of the rate at which you
cross fitness valleys.
So this is like tunneling
in quantum mechanics or so.
And it has a lot of
the same behaviors,
in the sense of exponential
suppression of probabilities
as a function of the depth and
the width of the valley you're
trying to traverse.
And there's some
very nice papers,
if you're interested in
looking at this stuff.
And one of them is actually in
the syllabus that I mentioned.
I'm trying to remember who.
It was Journal of
Theoretical Biology,
but I put it on as optional
reading for those of you
who are interested.
All right, OK.
So what I want to do now
is I want to switch gears,
so we can think about this
evolutionary game theory
business.
And I think the
most important thing
to stress when thinking about
evolutionary game theory
is just that this point that we
don't need to assume anything
about rationality.
Because the puzzles that we like
to give each other in your dorm
rooms Friday night,
you give these logic
puzzles to each other.
Is that-- I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, let me just say, back when I
was in college, that was, like,
all the cool kids were doing it.
But in these puzzles, you assume
that there's hyper-rationality.
You assume that
if this guy knows
that I did this,
and that, and if I
did that, he would do that.
And then you end
up, and then you
have the villagers
that are jumping off
cliffs on the seventh day.
Have you guys done
these puzzles?
No?
OK.
All right.
Well.
[LAUGHTER]
So the point was
that people assume
that when we're talking
about game theory,
you have to invoke this
hyper-rationality even
humans don't engage in.
And I think that it's
just very important
to remember that we're talking
about evolutionary game
theory in the case of,
well, biological evolution.
You don't assume anything
about rationality.
Instead, you simply have
mutations that sample
different strategies.
And then you have
differences in fitness
that just lead to evolution
towards the same solutions
of the game.
So it's evolution to
the game solutions,
so the Nash equilibrium,
for example.
So it's not that we
think that the cells are
engaging in any sort of
weird puzzle solving.
Instead, they're just mutations.
And the more fit individuals
spread in the population.
And somehow, you evolve to
the same or similar solutions,
to these Nash equilibria in
the context of game theory.
And we'll see how this plays
out in a few concrete examples.
Now, there are always different
ways of looking at these games.
One thing I want to
stress, though, is that all
the selection that
we've been talking
about in the last
few weeks, that all
is consistent with game
theory in the sense
that the idea of
the game theory is
that we allow for
the possibility
that the fitness of
individuals depends
upon the rest of the population.
Whereas in all these
calculations we've been doing,
I told you, all right, I
just gave you some fitnesses.
So I said, here we have a 0,
0 state that has some fitness.
0, 1 has a higher
fitness, and so forth.
But in general,
these fitness values
may depend upon what the
population composition is.
And in that situation, then you
want to use evolutionary game
theory.
In many cases,
people just assume
that you can do something like
this-- that you can describe it
as some fitness landscape.
But you can't do that if
there's this frequency-dependent
selection-- if there's any
sort of evolutionary game
interactions going on.
So it's just important.
If the fitnesses
depend on composition--
this is the population
composition--
then you cannot even
define a fitness landscape.
Then no fitness landscape.
For example, you can have
situations where the population
evolves to lower fitness.
So you can have a
situation where,
if I tell you individual
0, you measure its growth
rate, whatnot, its
fitness might be 1.
So this is genome,
and this is fitness.
Now, if I go and I
measure the fitness
of some other individual,
different genome-- so
another strain of bacteria
or yeast or whatever--
and you say, oh, well,
its fitness is 1.2.
So this strain has higher
fitness than this strain.
Now, it would be very natural
to assume that this strain will
out-compete this strain.
And indeed, that's been the
assumption in everything
we've been talking about.
But it's not necessarily true.
And that's the basic insight
of evolutionary game theory,
is that just knowing the
fitness of a pure population
is not actually enough
information to know that it's
going to be selected for.
Because it's still possible
that in a mixed population,
the genome 0 may actually
have higher fitness
than the genome 1.
And once you kind of
study these things,
it's kind of clear
that it can happen.
But then it's easy to
then go back to the lab
and forget that it's true.
And so we'll see
how this plays out.
AUDIENCE: On this game
theory, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
That's the other
thing, is that I
like to just draw these
things as graphs, because I
think it's much easier
to see what's happening.
And it's clear that
things can be non-linear.
But the basic insights
are all intact.
From my standpoint as kind
of an experimentalist--
don't forget about
the exam-- I think
that the more formal
evolutionary game theory
thing-- these two-player
games that you guys just
read about-- I think they're
important because they tell you
what are the possible outcomes
of measurements or of systems,
even in the most simple
situation where everything's
linear.
Now, when things are
not linear, of course
you can get even
richer dynamics.
But in practice, you basically
get the categories of outcomes
that we saw there.
So maybe what I'll do is--
so what we're going to do
is think about competition
between two individuals
A and B. And often, we
talk about these things
in the context of the two-player
games, where we have A, B, C,
D. And because this is really
importing the kind of approach,
or the nomenclature, from
conventional game theory,
and then immediately applying
it to populations where you just
assume that all the
individuals have
equal probability of
interacting with everybody
in the population.
So it's what you
would get if you just
had some two-player game like
they study in game theory,
but in a population
of 1,000 or whatnot.
You just made a bunch of
random pairwise interactions.
You had them play the game.
And then you had them
do that again over time.
And then this is the
payouts that you read about
in Chapter Four are kind
of what would happen
in that sort of situation,
where everybody's
interacting with everybody
else with equal probability.
Now, remember the
way that you read
this is that, depending upon
the strategy that these guys are
following, you get
different payouts.
And normally what we say
is that if this could be,
for example, strategy one and
two, strategy one and two.
And this is telling
us about the payout
that the A individual gets
depending on what he does,
and depending upon
what his opponent does.
Now, we're not explicitly
saying what the payout to the B
individual is,
but we're assuming
that this is a symmetric game,
so you could figure it out
by looking at the
opposite entry.
So if A follows strategy
one, B follows strategy one,
then individual A
gets little a fitness,
whereas B also gets
little a fitness,
because it's a symmetric game.
So the case it's different is
when we're in the diagonals.
And from this
framework, you can see
that there are
going to be already
a bunch of kind of
non-trivial things
that can happen, even in this
regime where everything's
linear.
And the probably best
well-known of these
is this Prisoner's
Dilemma, which
is the standard
model of cooperation
in the field of game theory.
So there's a story that
goes along with it.
It's this idea that-- I'm sure
you guys watch these cop shows,
where you have the cops
bring in the two accomplices.
And then they put them
in separate rooms.
And they tell them
that they have
to confess to
committing the crime,
because the guy in the
other room is confessing,
and if he doesn't
confess, then he's
going to be in
trouble, et cetera.
You've seen these cop shows?
And incidentally,
in these questions,
when cops are
questioning witnesses,
they're actually allowed to lie
to the person being questioned,
which feels a little
bit weird, actually.
Doesn't it?
I know, I know, this
is not relevant.
So the idea of the
prisoner's dilemma
is that if you set up these
jail sentences in the right way,
then it could be the case
that each individual has
the incentive to confess, even
though both individuals would
be better off if
they cooperated.
And you can come up with some
reasonable payout structure
that has that property.
And we'll call this-- so
this is for individual one,
say and individual two.
So there are different
strategies you can follow.
And do you guys remember
from the reading
slash my explanation how
to read these charts?
All right, now the question
is, just to remind ourselves,
what is the Nash
equilibrium of this game?
And I know that you read
about it last night.
Well, use your cards.
Is it C or is it D?
Or is there no Nash equilibrium,
you can flash something else.
AUDIENCE: Are those
negative or positive?
PROFESSOR: These are
positive fitness.
I kind of don't like the
Prisoner's Dilemma as a story,
because it's not very
intuitive, because you
have to actually
specify the jail terms,
and you have to remember that
jail terms are bad, not good.
So these are good things, OK?
These are years off
that you get as a result
of doing one thing or another.
You want to get big numbers.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
So at least we have a
majority that are D,
but it's not all of them.
And I think this is
basically a reflection--
and D is indeed the
Nash equilibrium.
It's to do this strategy
D that we're saying here.
All right, now the
question is why?
And part of the challenge
here is just understanding
how to read these charts.
Now, first of all, the payout
that everybody gets if everyone
follows strategy D is what?
Verbally, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: One.
PROFESSOR: So everybody
gets payout one.
Now, if you look
at this chart, you
say, well, gee, that is a shame.
Because 1 is just not the
biggest number you see here.
And indeed, the
important point to note
here is that if both players
had followed this strategy
C for cooperate, D for defect,
then both individuals would be
getting fitness 3, or payout 3.
So the idea here is that
both individuals would
do better if they both
played strategy C.
But the problem is that that's
not evolutionarily stable.
Or in the context
of game theory,
that is cheatable in some ways.
And so the reason that
this is a Nash equilibrium
is that you ask-- so a Nash
equilibrium, what it means,
if you recall, is
that if everyone's
playing that strategy, then
nobody has the incentive
to change strategy.
So no incentive to
change strategy.
So now you just
imagine, let's say,
that you're playing
against somebody else,
or in the context
of biology, it's
a population of individuals
following the D strategy.
The question is whether
you as an individual
would have the incentive to
switch to the other strategy?
And the answer is no, because
what you have control over
is this rows.
The column is specified by
the rest of the population.
So if you're in this state,
what you have a choice of
is to switch to the
cooperate strategy, which
would be to go up here.
So you have a choice to
move up to this 0 payout,
but that's not to
your advantage.
Now, it's true that your
opponent would get payout 5.
So you opponent would
actually do wonderfully.
But you would do poorly.
So you'd be selected
against, if you imagine
this being in the
context of biology--
that you have a genotype
that are playing
D. If you're a mutant that
starts following this strategy
C, you have lower fitness,
so you're selected against.
So that's saying that the
strategy D is noninvadable.
We can also think about
what happens if we're
a population of cooperators.
Now everybody has high
fitness-- fitness 3.
Question is, what
happens if there's
a mutation that leads to one
individual following the D
strategy?
Is he selected four or not?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes,
so the point here
is that you always will
have higher fitness,
regardless of what your opponent
does in the context of a game
theory situation, or
regardless of the distribution
of cooperation and
defection in the population.
It's always better
to be a defector.
So the problem here is, it's
always better to play D.
Now, I really like drawing
the graphs of these things,
because I think it's
just much more clear.
And you can either
draw the fitness
of the two types minus each
other, or just the raw fitness.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So what if
instead of 5, you have 7?
Because then the population
as a whole's fitness
decreases when you [INAUDIBLE].
So how does that--
PROFESSOR: So you're saying
if this 5 were a 7 instead?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Right, then
what you're saying
is that-- so it doesn't change.
The Nash equilibrium
is still defect.
The subtle thing here
is that, in general,
in terms of game theory, we like
it when the mean of these two
is smaller than this one.
That's why you're asking, right?
Exactly, because that's right.
Exactly, right.
So yeah, so that's a slightly
more complicated situation,
because in that situation, then,
if you had two rational agents,
say, playing this game, then
you could alternate cooperation
and defection.
And that would actually be the
ultimate form of cooperation
in such a game, because you
could actually get a higher
payout by alternating.
Right, so we've
chosen the numbers
as they are so that this is
subtlety is not an issue.
Does everybody understand
the issue there?
So in the context of
evolutionary game theory, what
we can do is we can plot as
a function of the fraction
of the population that's
cooperator between 0 and 1,
say.
And we can plot the
payout for the cooperator
and for the defector.
For example, I'm going to draw
a solid line for the cooperator,
dashed line for the defector.
Now the question is, what should
be the y-axes on either ends
and so forth?
Do you understand?
So what should these
things look like?
I'd like to encourage
you to-- I'll
give you 30 seconds
to try to draw
what this should look like.
So this is the payout
or the expected payout.
So we're assuming that you're
going to interact randomly
with the other members of
the population as a function
of the fraction cooperator.
So then 1 minus that will
be the fraction defector.
Do you understand what I'm
trying to ask you to do?
AUDIENCE: So the scale on
the right-hand side supposed
to be for the defectors?
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: This is just a
legend, or key, or something.
So I want you to draw
something over here that's
a solid line and a dashed line.
AUDIENCE: All right,
so it's just one scale.
And you don't--
PROFESSOR: It's one scale.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah, sorry.
I'm just telling you what's
going to be a solid line
and what's going to
be a dashed line.
And I'll give you a hint,
that up here is number 5.
This is going to be the expected
payout for a lone individual
given the rest of the
population is following
some fraction of cooperator.
Do you guys understand
what I'm asking you to do?
Because I'm a little
bit concerned that there
are very few plots in front.
AUDIENCE: What is fc?
PROFESSOR: So this is the
fraction of the population
that's cooperator.
Well, I was giving you a
chance to think about it.
But from looking around,
I think that maybe you're
not quite sure what I'm
trying to ask you to do.
So I'm trying to plot
the expected payout
for an individual that is
either cooperating or defecting,
based on the fact that
the rest of the population
has some composition between
all cooperate or all defect.
So it's the evolution
game theory extension
of this simple model.
So first, we can ask, well,
if the entire population is
cooperating, we want to know
the fitness for a cooperator
or defector.
Well, this is really
just saying that we're
all the way over on here, and
we just choose between the two.
And the defector is the 5 one.
So this is going to be
a dashed line that's
going to start from here.
And then this is 2 and 1/2, 3.
So this is cooperator starts
here, and defector starts here.
Do you understand what I'm?
Now, OK, let's see.
So now this is the one where
if everybody else is defecting,
well, now, the cooperator
line goes to what?
Verbally, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0.
The defector line goes to 1.
OK, that line, I started
going the wrong direction,
but that's supposed
to be a line.
So this is an
example of what this
looks like for the
Prisoner's Dilemma.
And what you see is
the defector fitness
is always above the
cooperator fitness.
So for any population
composition,
defectors have higher
fitness than cooperators.
So evolution brings you to
the pure defecting state,
where you have fitness 1.
And if you want,
you could calculate
what the mean fitness of the
population is, for example.
And the mean fitness
starts out over here,
and ends up over here.
So the mean fitness
decreases over time.
Now, you can imagine that in
the simple, two-player models,
all these are lines.
But you can imagine that the
only thing that's important
are how these lines
cross each other.
So for example, there are
only a few different things
that can happen.
You can have one
strategy that dominates,
which is what occurred here.
And surprisingly,
that does not mean
that that strategy
is higher fitness,
in the sense that you may evolve
to a state of low fitness.
That's what's weird.
You can have coexistence, or
you can have bi-stability.
So I'll give you
another example of this.
So now we're just going
to have two strategies.
The strategies-- we'll
just call them A and B.
And the question is, what
is the Nash equilibrium?
Is it A, B, or C should
be neither, D is both.
Do you understand?
I'm going to ask, because
if this is the game
and this is the interaction,
is the Nash equilibrium A,
Nash equilibrium B?
If you vote C, it means
neither, D means both.
Do you understand the question?
I'll give you 30 seconds
to think about it.
All right, are we ready to vote?
Ready, three, two, one.
All right, so we have
a fair distribution.
I may not have us vote,
but yeah, in this case,
they're actually
both Nash equilibria.
So let's see this.
If both individuals, or
an entire population,
say, is playing A,
they're getting fitness 5.
Question is, as a
lone individual,
you can choose to switch
over and get fitness 3.
Do you want to do that?
No.
So that means that A is going
to be a Nash equilibrium.
Incidentally, the
difference between
the so-called regular Nash
equilibrium and the strict Nash
equilibrium is that
Nash equilibrium
means that no individual has the
incentive to change strategy.
A strict Nash equilibrium means
that any change in strategy
leads to an actual
decrease in fitness.
So it's a question of whether
you can make neutral changes
in strategy or not.
Do you understand?
So A is a Nash equilibrium.
What about B?
Well, in that case, everybody's
getting to fitness 1.
Now, as a lone individual,
what can you do?
All you can do is switch.
As an individual, you
can only choose rows.
So you go up to 0.
That's a decrease of fitness.
So that means that strategy
B is also a Nash equilibrium.
So there are two Nash
equilibria in this game.
And what does that
mean about which regime
you're in here, if you convert
this into an evolutionary game
theory scenario?
Ready, three, two, one.
OK, so a majority is saying yes.
This is indeed a situation in
which you have bi-stability.
So what does that mean in terms
of these lines if we draw them?
So this is payout as a
function of the fraction that
is playing the A strategy.
Should the lines cross?
Yes or no?
Ready, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes, and
indeed, in principle,
the math that we do in
all these situations
is kind of super simple.
Yet it's easy to get confused
about what's going on
in all these situations.
So the idea here is that if
the population is A, that
means that the A here is at 5.
But then it goes down to 0.
Whereas over here, B here is 3.
And then it goes to 1.
Because these two
lines cross, does that
mean that you have bi-stability?
Ready, yes or no,
three, two, one,
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No, and why not?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right,
because you can also
do the other thing, and then
that leads to coexistence.
Now, in some ways coexistence
is the most subtle
of the situations.
And that's for an
interesting reason.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, sir,
you said you can also
do the other thing.
What is the other thing here?
PROFESSOR: I'm saying
that these things can
cross in the other orientation.
Let me put a matrix
out there, and then--
so this is something that,
for example, is what's
known as a Hawk/Dove game.
Or it has many other names.
And we can maybe figure out
what would be the Hawk strategy,
and what's the Dove strategy.
Now, we want to ask the
same question-- is A a Nash
equilibrium?
Is B a Nash equilibrium?
Is it neither?
Or is it both?
And maybe I shouldn't
have covered this up,
so you're not influenced,
in case you actually
did do the reading.
Then I don't want to you
to be influenced by this.
So think about it
for 30 seconds.
Do you need more time?
Let's go see where we are.
Ready, three, two, one.
All right, so most of the
group is agreeing in this case,
neither are the
Nash equilibrium.
So neither are a
Does that mean that this
game has no Nash equilibrium?
Yes or no, verbally--
ready, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No, it
does not mean that.
This game has a
Nash equilibrium.
And indeed, all games like
this have Nash equilibria.
And this is what Nash
won the Nobel Prize for,
so this is the famous one-page
paper published in PNAS.
If you look at it, I have
no idea what it says.
I mean, he basically
just pointed out
that this theorem implies
this, implies that-- done.
And so it's good that somebody
knew what he was saying,
otherwise we'd be in
trouble, all of us.
So what he proved
is that such games,
even with more players,
more options, and so forth,
they always have such a
solution in this sense.
There exists some strategy
such as if everybody
were playing in, nobody
would have the incentive
to change strategy.
But you have to include
so-called probabilistic or
mixed strategies.
And we can draw
what this thing is.
So just like always, so
everyone else is following A,
then A starts here at 3.
And then it goes to 1.
Whereas the B individuals
start at 5, and they go to 0.
So this looks very
similar to that,
but they're rather
different, in the sense
that in this situation,
we had bi-stability.
So if you look at the
direction of evolution,
depending upon
where you start, you
go to either all B
or all A. Whereas
in this situation over
here, we have coexistence.
Does not matter where you start.
So long as you have some
members of both A and B
in the population, you'll always
evolve to the same equilibrium.
Now, the important thing
here that's, I think,
interesting is that
in a population,
if you have genetic A's and
genetic B's that are each
giving birth to
their own type, then
you evolve to some
coexistence of genotypes.
So here, this is some fraction.
f a star is the equilibrium
fraction, fraction
of A in the population.
So this is a case where you
have genetic diversity that
leads to phenotypic
diversity in the population.
Whereas the mixed Nash
equilibrium-- this
is a situation where
you have, in principle,
genetic homogeneity.
So this is a single genotype
that is implementing
phenotypic heterogeneity.
And indeed, one of
the things that we've
been excited about
exploring in my group
is this distinction here, where
it's known that in many cases,
isogenic populations
of microbes can exhibit
a diversity of phenotypes
as a result of, for example,
stochastic gene expression
and bi-stability.
So that's a molecular
mechanism for how
you might get heterogeneity.
Another question is, what
is the evolution explanation
for why that behavior
might have evolved?
Now in general, we cannot
prove why something evolved,
but we can make educated
guesses that make experimentally
testable hypotheses.
And for example,
in the experiment
that we've been doing, we've
been looking at bi-modality
in expression of the
galactose genes in yeast.
And that was still a
problem set in early-- oh,
no, we removed
that one this year.
Well, so experimentally
yeast, in some environments,
bimodally or
stochastically activate
the genes required to break
down the sugar galactose.
And what we've
demonstrated is that if you
make the mutants that always
turn on or always don't
turn on these genes, then
they're actually playing game
where you actually get
this exact thing-- where
you get evolution towards
coexistence of those two
strategies.
So that's saying that
maybe the wild type that
follows this stochastic,
mixed strategy-- it
may be implementing the
solution of some game that
is a result of such
frequency dependence.
There are other possible
explanations to this.
In the coming weeks,
we'll talk about this idea
of bet hedging-- that given
uncertain or fluctuating
environments, it
may be advantageous
for clonal populations to have a
variety of different strategies
to cope with that uncertainty.
So we'll talk about
those models later.
But since we're talking
about mixed strategies now,
I wanted to mention that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So f a
star, just to be sure,
is going to converge to this
probability [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Exactly, so the
Nash equilibrium mixed strategy
plays A with probability--
so it's p should
be equal to f a star.
Exactly, so indeed,
the heterogeneity there
can be implemented either way.
It's either coexistence
of genotypes following
different strategies,
or it could
be one genotype
implementing both,
or it could be a mixture
of those, actually.
Indeed, a characteristic
of these situations
is that, let's say that you have
a genotype-- a population has
this genotype that is
implementing the mixed Nash
equilibrium choosing strategy
A with probability p.
That's that
equilibrium fraction.
What's interesting is
that any individual
in the population following any
strategy has the same fitness.
And of course, that's kind of
why this was in equilibrium.
This equilibrium is when the two
strategies have equal fitness.
But the funny thing
is, what that means
is, it doesn't matter what
you do at the equilibrium.
Depending on how you
look at it, it's either
super deep or super trivial.
But it's a weird thing that
if your at the equilibrium,
or if the population
or the opponent
is playing this Nash
equilibrium in these games,
then it just does not
matter what you do.
You can do A. You can do B,
actually, in any fraction.
So since A and B have
the same fitness,
you can choose between them
at any frequency you want,
and you have the same fitness,
if the rest of the population
is playing this mixed
Nash equilibrium.
And indeed, in this
there are nice conditions
for what makes it
this Nash equilibrium.
And I'm going to just highlight
that you should make sense
of why it means what it is.
So if the payout, the
expected fitness or payout--
if you're following
the Nash equilibrium
against Nash equilibrium--
is equal to this guy.
So that's what I
just said-- that it
doesn't matter what you do.
If everyone else
is doing p star,
you have the same fitness.
So that's saying it's
a Nash equilibrium.
Whereas there's another
interesting kind of statement
here, that--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
That you can't unilaterally
increase your fitness
by switching.
PROFESSOR: Right, it's
an equality, which
means it is a Nash equilibrium.
Because it's saying that
you don't have the incentive
to change strategy.
It's true that you're
not dis-incentivized.
So it's a Nash equilibrium.
It's not a strict
Nash equilibrium.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, it has to
be greater than/equal to,
and it's actually equal to.
The condition it has to be
greater than or equal to,
but it's equal to, which means
it is a Nash equilibrium.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Nash
equilibrium for that situation,
[INAUDIBLE] strategy.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So this is not the
definition of that.
But this thing is
true, which means
that it's a Nash equilibrium.
And this other thing that's
interesting is that--
so this tells us that it's
actually one of these ESS's.
And if you have questions about
this, I'm happy to answer it.
It's explained in
the book as well.
We are out of time, so
I should let you go.
But good luck on the
exam next Thursday.
If you have questions and
you want to meet with me,
I'm available on Tuesday.
So please let me know.